es wird wahrscheinlich größte kosmische
katastrophe die wir von der erde aus
beobachtet werden können weil
supermassereiche schwarze löcher wird
mir ineinander und verschmelzen dabei
werden gravitationswellen ausgesandt
viele so noch nie beobachtet hat eine
immense krümmung der raumzeit doch ist
ein führen die beiden einen
spektakulären puzzles anlauf wann diese
katastrophe passiert und wie wir sie
hier auf der erde spüren werden jetzt
täglich vom science fiction herzlich
willkommen das schwarze löcher öfter
miteinander verschmelzen das wissen wir
seit anfang 2000 rechnen hat damals die
entdeckung von gravitationswellen
verkündet wurde
zwei schwarze löcher waren ineinander
gestürzt und hatten die raumzeit so sehr
gekrümmt was es hier auf der erde
gemessen werden konnte geschehen in
laser interferometer die technologie fox
resource kurz lego in den usa das
prinzip wenn die gravitationswellen wie
ein stein im wasser wellen auslösen und
so die raumzeit kommen werden sie auch
die bahn von nicht verändern licht hat
ja eine unveränderliche geschwindigkeit
von 299 millionen gewinner 2009 58 meter
pro sekunde
wenn aber eine gravitationswellen
lichtstrahl durch kreuz muss er sich
verändern da ja die raumzeit gekrümmt
wird und damit auch die zeit verändert
wird er nicht preis würde vermeintlich
seine geschwindigkeit verändert
beziehungsweise eine andere distanz
durchlaufen um das zu messen werden in
den gravitationswellen detektoren zwei
lichtstrahlen auf zwei strecken
rechtwinklig zueinander geführt beim
lego bünder 24 kilometer lange röhren
dort wird ein laserstrahl der mit einem
prisma in zwei aufgezeigt wird mehrmals
hin und her geschickt und die
lichtwellen dann so zusammengeführt dass
sie sich gegenseitig auslöschen
denn wer vom schallwellen können sich
gegenseitig komplett auslöschen wenn
wellentäler und wellenberge genau
übereinander liegen genau so wird das in
den karikaturen schwellen detektoren mit
licht gemacht passiert jetzt eine
gravitationswellen dem detektor werden
beide laserstrahlen unterschiedlich
beeinflusst war wer rechtwinklig
zueinander laufen die löschen sich nicht
mehr aus und ein licht mit erscheint
gravitationswellen gefunden
gravitationswellen
kommen den raum allerdings ein wenig
über einen hauch weshalb es ist auch
sehr lange gedauert bis wir entdeckt
haben aber was wäre wenn die raumzeit so
stark gekrümmt würde dass wir es mit
bloßem auge sehen würden
das wäre schon zurück plötzlich rabatt
alles um uns herum
die katastrophe die sich jetzt ankündigt
ist jedenfalls rund mehrere millionen
mal größer als die bisher beobachteten
verschmelzungen von schwarzen löchern
die beiden gefundenen schwarzen löcher
im todeskampf habe mich zusammen 15
milliarden sonnenmassen
das allein ist schon spektakulär
überhaupt ist auch ihre entdeckung
spektakulär nur wenn zwei galaxien
miteinander verschmelzen werden in ihrem
zentrum 2 supermassereiche schwarze
löcher vermutet die galaxie 04.02 plus 3
79 war also mal wahrscheinlich zwei
galaxien die verschmolzen sind
dass wir wissen dass die beiden
schwarzen löcher im zentrum auch diesen
todestages vollführen ist einer der lang
andauernde beobachtung zu verpacken
gerichte existenz wurde schon 2006
festgestellt aber was machen diese
beiden supermassereichen schwarzen
löcher wie verhalten sich zueinander er
als zehn jahre wurden die beiden
gegangen beobachtet und es wurden immer
mehr daten gesammelt entfernung 24
lichtjahre matte 15 milliarden
sonnenmassen dauer der gegenseitigen
umkreisung 24.000 jahren
das ist als wenn man eine schnecke auf
den planeten um proxima centauri
beobachten würde sie mit einem
zentimeter pro sekunde vor ließ dabei
aber um vier lichtjahre entfernt ist
dieser bewegung ähnlichen drehimpuls
müssen wir hier auflösen da sagte romani
avco autor dieser untersuchung von der
stanford university und sie haben es
geschafft es hat nur etwas gedauert
das ist aber nicht gegenüber der zeit
die wir abwarten müssen bis es endlich
passiert aber wahrscheinlich wird dann
auch nicht der ganze raum bahn sondern
wir werden es nur an einem
gravitationswellen detektor feststellen
können erst in rund einer million jahren
werden die beiden schwarzen löcher
wahrscheinlich verschmelzen wenn es also
passiert dann erfahrt ihr natürlich hier
nur noch 365 millionen videos bis dahin
wenn er sie verpassen wollen hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht nehmen
auch die glauben hier geht es zu einem
schwarzen loch das auf einer galaxie
katapultiert wurde
wahrscheinlich als die beiden schwarzen
löcher in ihrem zentrum verschmolzen
wenn ihr euch für diese kosmische
katastrophe interessiert einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten gesang bleibt
dran